[MUSIC PLAYING]
HARRY: I have to say I
personally believe that
the timing cannot be any better
to have Congressman John Lewis
here.
With tensions in the
country running high
and individuals
looking for guidance,
I believe Congressman John
Lewis is the perfect person
to hear from at this time.
Congressman Lewis served as
chair of the SNCC or Student
Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee
when he was a student at
Fisk, during the Civil Rights
Movement, and led
several marchings,
including the march
across the Edmund Pettus
Bridge in Selma, Alabama,
which is known today
as Bloody Sunday.
Serving in the United
States Congress,
Congressman Lewis has
made his life-long goal
to fight for civil and
human rights for all.
A true champion
for us all, please
welcome Congressman John Lewis.
[APPLAUSE]
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Good morning.
I'm delighted, very
happy, and very pleased
to be here at Google.
Thank you so much.
You look good.
Thank you, Harry, for those
kind words of introduction.
I'm happy and pleased to be
here with my co-author, Andrew
Aydin.
It was his idea that got
me involved in this effort.
And we're so grateful that
you ally two guys that
were born-- one born in
Atlanta, one in rural Alabama--
to come from the South.
Andrew would tell you that
I've been his congressperson
since he was only
three years old.
So the people in Georgia
have been very good to me.
Now I didn't grow up in
a big city like Atlanta.
I grew up in rural Alabama,
50 miles from Montgomery.
My father was a sharecropper--
a tenant farmer.
But back in 1944 when I
was only four years old--
and I do remember
when I was four--
my father had saved $300.
And with the $300 he
bought 110 acres of land.
My family still owns
this land today.
On this farm we raised a lot of
cotton and corn, peanuts, hogs,
cows, and chickens.
I'll be very frank and
very honest with you,
I didn't like working
out in the field.
I didn't like being
out in the hot sun.
And I did everything possible
to escape working in the field.
I used to say to
my mother when I
would fall behind picking
cotton or gathering peanuts,
she would say, "Boy, catch up.
You're lagging behind.
Catch up."
And I would say,
"This is hard work."
And she would say, "Boy, hard
work never killed anybody.
It won't kill you."
I said, well, it's
about to kill me.
So during my early days
in school, especially
middle school, I would get
up early in the morning,
pack my book bag and hide
under the front porch
and wait until the
school bus come along
to get off to school.
Somehow I discovered that
education was important.
Now you heard me say
it earlier that we
raised a lot of chickens.
I know here at Google
you're just smart.
I can tell.
But do you know anything
about raising chickens?
You know something about
raising a chicken, brother?
AUDIENCE: Not much.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Not much?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
my grandmother's farm.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: OK.
Well, why don't we
compare notes here?
AUDIENCE: We used to go out
and grab the eggs [INAUDIBLE].
We were kids.
We'd just run in there and
grab what we would want.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: Oh.
Well, let's just
compare notes here.
And let's have fun here.
Well, on the farm really
was my responsibility
to care for the chickens.
And I became very good, really
good at raising chickens.
When the setting hen was set,
I would take a fresh eggs,
mark them with a pencil, place
them under the setting hen,
and wait for three long weeks
for the chicks to hatch.
You may be saying,
"Now John Lewis,
why did you mark those
fresh eggs with a pencil
before we placed them
under the setted hen?"
well, from time to
time, another hen
would get on that same nest.
There would be some
more eggs-- fresh eggs.
Had to wait until the fresh eggs
for the eggs that were already
under the setting hen.
Do you follow me?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: OK.
Good.
When the little
chick would hatch,
I would fool the setting hen.
I would cheat on
their setting hen.
I would take these little chicks
and give them to another hen
or put them in a
box with a lantern,
raise them on their own.
I was never quite
able to save $18.98
to order the most
inexpensive incubator
or hatcher from the
Sears and Roebuck Store.
Most of you in here are so
young you don't know anything
about the Sears and
Roebuck catalog, do you?
You really do?
Really?
That big book?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: That thick book?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: That heavy book?
Some people called
it the wish book.
I wish I had this.
I wish I had that.
So I just kept on
wishing as a little boy.
But as a little child, I
wanted to be a minister.
I wanted to preach the gospel.
So from time to time to
helping my brothers and sisters
and cousins, we would
gather all of our chickens
together in the chicken
yard like you're
gathered here in this room.
The chickens, along with
my brothers and sisters
and cousins, would make up the
audience, the congregation.
And I would start
speaking or preaching.
And when I look back on
it, some of these chickens
would bow their heads.
Some of these chickens
would shake their heads.
They never quite said Amen.
But I'm convinced that some of
those chickens that I preached
to in the '40s and
the '50s tended
to listen to me much better
than some of my colleagues
listen to me today
in the Congress.
And some of those chickens were
just a little more productive.
At least they produced eggs.
So that's the chicken story.
And that's enough of that story.
But if we were to visit
the little town of Troy,
or visit Montgomery, visit
Tuskegee, visit Birmingham,
I saw those signs that said
white men, colored men,
white women, colored women,
white waiting, colored waiting.
And I didn't like it.
To go downtown to the theatre
on a Saturday afternoon,
all of us little black
children had to go upstairs
to the balcony.
All of the little white
children went downstairs
to the first floor.
I would come home and
ask my mother, my father,
my grandparents, my
great-grandparents why.
And they would say,
that's the way it is.
Don't get in the way.
Don't get in trouble.
But one day I heard
about Rosa Parks,
15 years old in the 10th grade.
I heard the words of
Martin Luther King, Junior,
on our radio.
The action of Rosa Parks,
the words and leadership
of Dr. King inspired
me to find a way
to get in the way to get in,
what I called, good trouble,
necessary trouble.
So in 1956, at the
age of 16, with some
of my brothers and
sisters and cousins,
we went down to
the public library
in a little town
of Troy Alabama,
trying to get a library card
to check out some books.
And we were told
by the librarian
that the library was for
whites only and not for colors.
I never went back to that
library to that building
until July 5, 1998,
for a book signing
of my first book,
"Walking with to Wind."
And hundreds of black and
white citizens showed up,
and they gave me a library card.
It says something about
the distance we have come
and the progress we have made in
laying down the burden of race.
I don't know how many of you
have heard of Troy University.
It was called Troy State
when I was growing up.
Only 10 miles from my home.
Age of 17, 1957, I applied
to go to the school.
Submitted my application,
my high school transcript.
I never heard a word
from the school.
So I wrote a letter to Dr.
Martin Luther King, Junior.
I didn't tell my
mother, my father,
any of my sisters or
brothers, any of my teachers.
I told Dr. King I
needed his help.
Martin Luther King,
Junior, wrote me back,
sent me a round trip
Greyhound bus ticket,
and invited me to come to
Montgomery to meet with him.
In the meantime, I
had been accepted
at a little school in
Nashville, Tennessee.
So in September,
1957, an uncle of mine
gave me a $100 bill-- more
money than I ever had.
Gave me one of these
big foot-lockers,
these up-right trunks
that you can open up then
bring it back together,
that had to drawers
that you could put things in.
And then a compartment
where you can hang-- Andy,
you remember that foot locker?
I still have that foot locker.
It's big and old.
But I boarded that
bus-- a Greyhound bus.
And I put everything that
I own in that foot locker,
except those chickens, and went
off to school to Nashville.
And after being in
Nashville for a few weeks,
I told one of my
teachers that I'd
been in contact with Doctor
Martin Luther King, Junior.
This teacher knew Doctor King.
Both had studied at Morehouse
College, the same school
that Harry Johnson studied.
And he informed Dr. King
that I was in Nashville.
Martin Luther King,
Junior, got in touch
and suggested when I went
home for Spring Break
to come and see him.
So in March of 1958-- by
this time I'm 18 years old--
my father drove me to the
Greyhound bus station.
I boarded the bus and
traveled to Montgomery.
And a young lawyer--
I'd never seen a lawyer
before-- a young man by
the name of Fred Gray,
who had been a lawyer
for Rosa Parks,
for Dr. King, and the
Montgomery Movement,
and became our lawyer during
the freedom rides and the march
from Selma to Montgomery,
met me at the bus station
and drove me to the
First Baptist Church
in downtown Montgomery,
pastored by the Reverend Ralph
Abernathy, and then ushered me
into the office of the church.
I saw Martin Luther
King, Junior,
and Ralph Abernathy
standing behind a desk.
I was so scared.
I didn't know to
say or what to do.
And Dr. King said, "Are
you the boy from Troy?
Are you John Lewis?"
And I said, "Dr. King,
I am John Robert Lewis."
I gave my whole name.
And that was the beginning
of my involvement
with Martin Luther King, Junior.
And it changed my life forever,
and I have not looked back.
I had a discussion
with my parents.
They were so frightened
when I got back home.
They thought our
house would be bombed,
that we would lose the land.
And so I continued to
study in Nashville.
So it was in Nashville
that we started
studying the way of
peace, the way of love,
the way of non-violence.
That we start sitting
in, be sitting there
in an orderly, peaceful,
nonviolent fashion,
waiting to be
served, and someone
would come up and spit on us
or put lighted cigarettes out
in our hair or down our
backs, pour hot water,
hot coffee, hot chocolate on us.
We just stayed there,
looking straight ahead.
And Andrew Aydin will tell
you that the first time
I was arrested on February
27, 1960, just turned 20.
He discovered, a few
weeks ago, a photograph
of my first arrest.
In Nashville during the '60s and
many other parts of the South,
we wanted to sort of dress
up, put on our Sunday
best when we went to
participate in a protest.
I didn't have much or any money.
I wanted a new suit.
So I went to used men's
store in downtown Nashville,
and I bought a suit.
Now to tell you how much
a suit costs, it was $5.
I wish I still had it.
I don't know what
I would do with it.
I just don't know what
But maybe I would give
it to some museum.
Maybe the Smithsonian
or someplace.
I don't know.
But I looked good.
If you come to Washington,
we have a photograph
of that suit and I
me being arrested.
And you can see it.
So I would invite
any of you who want
to be in Washington
any time to come
by my congressional office.
It looks like a working museum.
But we didn't give up.
We didn't give in.
We kept the faith.
We kept our eyes on the prize.
We didn't become bitter.
We didn't become hostile.
Many of us accepted the way
of peace, the way of love,
the way of non-violence as a
way of life, as a way of living.
So during the '60s I was
arrested 40 times, left beaten.
Just think, 1961, the same year
that President Barack Obama was
born, black people
and white people
couldn't leave together
on a bus or train
with white people seated
together traveling to the south
to Virginia through
North Carolina,
through South Carolina, through
Georgia, Alabama, Mississippi,
on our way to New Orleans.
Many people came from
the state of California
during the freedom riot.
They came to Selma.
50 years ago this summer,
many came to Mississippi.
I'm going to cut it short and
leave some time for Andrew.
But during the
March on Washington,
I was the youngest speaker.
I spoke number six.
Dr. King spoke number 10.
There was 10 of us.
Out of the 10 people
that spoke that day,
I'm the only one still around.
When the March on
Washington was over,
President Kennedy invited us all
back down to the White House.
He stood in the door of the Oval
Office greeting each one of us.
And he kept saying he was
beaming like a proud father.
He kept saying,
you did a good job.
You did a good job.
And when he got to Dr. Martin
Luther King, Junior, he said,
"And you had a dream."
it was my last time
seeing President Kennedy.
Those of us that organized
the march to leadership,
we emerged black
and white as a circa
of trust, a band of
brothers and sisters.
But 18 days after the
March on Washington
was a terrible bombing of
the church in Birmingham
where four little girls were
killed on a Sunday morning
because of what happened.
We intensified our efforts
to gain the right to vote.
Just think, in a state
like Mississippi in 1964,
the state had a black
voting age population
of more than 450,000,
and only about 16,000
registered to vote.
And there was one county in
a state of Alabama-- Lowndes
County.
Between Selma and Montgomery--
the county was more than 80%
African American, but there
was not a single registered
African American
voter in the county.
In some parts of the South,
in Alabama and Mississippi,
people were asked to count
the number of bubbles
in a bar of soap, count the
number of jelly beans in a jar.
The [INAUDIBLE] section
of the Constitution
of Mississippi or the state of
Alabama or the US Constitution.
People were beaten, people were
arrested, people were jailed.
Three young men-- Andy Goodman,
Mickey Schwerner and James
Chaney-- went out on a summer
night of June 21, 1964,
to investigate the burning of
an African American church,
the church which would be
used for voter registration
workshop.
These three young men were
detained by the sheriff,
arrested, taken to jail,
and later that evening
taken out of jail,
turned over to that Klan
where they were beaten,
shot, and killed.
These three young men didn't die
in the Middle East or Eastern
Europe.
They didn't die in Vietnam,
Central South America.
They died right here
in our own country.
And that's why I say to young
people today and those of us
not so young, the
vote is precious.
And a democracy such as
ours is almost sacred.
And that's why we
all must participate
in the political process.
President Lyndon Johnson signed
the Civil Rights Act of '64
on July 2.
Dr. King received the Nobel
Peace Prize in December, 1964.
He come back from Europe, hold
a meeting at the White House
and said to President Johnson,
we need a Voter Rights Act.
President Johnson
said, I cannot do it.
We don't have of the
votes in the Congress.
I cannot get it passed.
Dr. King made a
decision to go to Selma
and join the students in the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee.
In Selma, only 2.1% of
blacks of voting age
were registered to vote.
You could only
attempt to register
to vote on the first and
third Mondays of each month,
and you had to go down
to the courthouse.
And in Selma you had a sheriff
who was a very big man, tall,
he was mean.
He got up mean.
He would sleep mean
and dream mean.
He was just mean.
He work a gun on one side, a
night stick on the other side,
and he carried an electric
cow prodder in this hand.
And he didn't use it on cows.
Many of us were arrested
by him for standing in line
and encouraging people to
stay in line and attempt
to get their literacy test
or attempt to pass their test
to become a registered voter.
But on March 7, 1965,
600 of us attempted
to walk from Selma to
Montgomery, Alabama,
50 miles away, to dramatize
to the state of Alabama,
to the nation, and to the
world, that people wanted
to participate in a
democratic process.
We were orderly.
I was wearing a
backpack before it
became fashionable
to wear backpacks.
And in this backpack
I had two books.
I wanted to have
something to read in jail.
I had one apple and one orange.
I wanted to have
something to eat.
Now one apple and one orange
wouldn't last that long.
And since I was
going to be in jail
with my friends and my
colleagues and neighbors,
I wanted to be able
to brush my teeth, so
toothpaste and toothbrush.
We get to the highest point
on the Edmund Pettus Bridge,
crossing the Alabama River.
Down below we saw a sea of
blue Alabama State Troopers.
Continued to walk.
We came within hearing
distance of the state troopers.
A major spoke up and said, "I'm
Major John Cloud of the Alabama
State Troopers.
This is an unlawful march.
It will not be
allowed to continue.
I give you three minutes
to disperse and return
to your homes or
to your church."
A young man from Dr.
King's organization
leading the march with
me said, "Major, give us
a moment to kneel and pray."
And the major said,
"Troopers, advance."
You saw these guys putting
on their gas masks.
They came toward us, beating
us with night sticks and bull
whips, trampling us with horses
and releasing the tear gas.
I was the first
person to be attacked.
Hit in the head by a state
trooper with a night stick,
had a concussion at the bridge,
I thought it was going to die.
I thought I saw death.
Next year will be
the 50th anniversary
of the march from
Selma to Montgomery.
Finally, we made it there.
The next day, Dr. King
came and said to me,
"We'll make it from
Selma to Montgomery.
The Voting Rights
Act will be passed."
He issued a call for religious
leaders to come to Selma.
On the following Tuesday, more
than 1,000 ministers, priests,
rabbis, and nuns came and
walked across that bridge.
President Johnson made one of
the most meaningful speeches
that any American president
had made in modern time
on the whole question of
Civil Rights or voting rights.
And the near the end
of that speech after he
had introduced the
Voting Rights Act,
he used the theme song to
the Civil Rights Movement
and he said, "And
we shall overcome."
I was sitting next to
Martin Luther King, Junior,
in a home of a local family
there in Selma, Alabama,
as we witnessed and
listened to Lyndon Johnson.
And when President Johnson
said, we shall overcome,
I looked at Dr. King.
And tears came down this face.
And we all cried
a little to hear
the President of the United
States state we shall overcome.
So because of the action
and the marching feet
of so many people, America's
a different America.
It's a better America.
We're not there yet.
We still have a distance to go.
But in the final
analysis, we all
must keep in mind that we're
one people, we're one family,
we're one house.
It doesn't matter whether
we're black or white or Latino,
Asian American or
Native American.
It doesn't matter whether
we're straight or gay,
we're all a member
of the human family.
We must look out for each
other and care for each other.
In closing I say thank you,
Google-- the Google family--
for all that you do to
bring this little spaceship,
the members of the human
race, a little closer
together as one
people and one family.
And now let me pause and yield
to my friend, my brother,
and someone acts
almost like he's
my son, Andrew Aydin,
the co-author on "March."
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW AYDIN: How
do you follow that?
Perhaps some of you are
asking, why would John Lewis
write a graphic novel?
And it's a fair question.
But what I hope to
tell you real quickly
is a story about how Dr. King,
himself, used one as well.
When I was on the
campaign in 2008,
I was going to a comic
book convention afterwards.
And I admitted it.
I said it out loud
to my colleagues,
and they laughed at me.
And Congressman
said, "Don't laugh.
There was a comic book
during the Movement,
and it was incredibly
influential."
And right off the bat it
started a conversation
with me wondering why doesn't
John Lewis write a comic book?
Why doesn't he tell
his story because he's
lived so much of the seminal
moments of the Movement.
If they used a comic book
once to help teach people
about nonviolence, why
can't we do it again?
And at the same time I
went back to Washington
after this campaign was over.
I went to grad school
at night and started
working on my graduate thesis.
And I decided to write
about Martin Luther
King and the Montgomery
story-- this comic book.
You might not know
it, because it
is sort of one of those
under-told stories,
but what we found out
was Dr. King edited it,
it was endorsed by
A. Philip Randolph,
and it was used
throughout the South
by people like Jim
Lawson, Congressman Lewis'
mentor in Nashville, to
educate and, in fact,
inspire some of the
earliest sit-ins.
And so, it seemed almost
self-evident to me
that perhaps we
could do it again.
That we're facing
the same struggles--
we see police brutality,
attacks on voting rights--
how do we get a young
activist generation to step up
again and fight
that fight with us?
There's three things
you need in a movement.
You need financing.
You need adequate
tools and strategy.
And you need activists
willing to give everything
that they can.
And it has to be young people.
They're the most free.
They're the most liberated.
They don't have mortgages.
They don't have families.
They don't have kids.
They're the only ones
who can put themselves
on the line as young radicals,
as they called the Congressman,
for believing simply that a
sixth grade education should
not be a requirement to
vote, as was proposed
in the original
Civil Rights Bill.
So, when I asked the
Congressman why don't you
write a comic book, he
sort of looked at me
and said, you know, oh.
Maybe a nod.
But I kept asking and asking.
And finally he said, OK.
Let's do it, but only
if you write it with me.
And it was one of those
challenges in my life
that you rarely get.
And if you let it
go, you've missed
this incredible opportunity.
But more importantly, perhaps
missed your own life's mission.
And I couldn't do that.
I grabbed onto it.
And for five years--
Harry knows this.
He saw me at night and
on weekends-- worrying
about that dad gum comic book.
Because that's when we
had a day job, and so
we were doing it at
night, on the phone,
when we could get together.
And we put our heart
and soul into it.
It grew from one book to three,
because what do you leave out?
Whose story don't you tell?
What key part of the
Civil Rights Movement
is not worth telling?
And low and behold,
it started to seem
like it was going to work.
There were some surreal
moments along the way.
One of them was I was on the
pilgrimage with the Congressman
and I get on an
elevator, and there
is Ethel Kennedy,
Robert Kennedy's widow,
and John Seigenthaler,
who was Robert Kennedy's
aid during the Freedom
Rides and later
the publisher of the
National Tennessean.
And this is a theme.
Again, I was young and
didn't know any better.
And so I asked.
I said, I'm sorry to
bother you, but I just
thought you'd want to know.
You're in a comic book
that I'm working on
with the Congressman.
And Ethel Kennedy looked up at
me with these beautiful eyes
and she just said,
"That's nice dear."
So it was a tremendous thrill
when she called me about
a year-and-a-half later
to say that "March"
book one would be the first
graphic novel ever to receive
the Robert F Kennedy Book Award.
The moment, though,
I think when we
knew that this book
was really going
to be something special,
that it was actually
going to work as a
tool for nonviolence
and teaching another
generation was right
after we had the first
advance copies out.
And I got a phone
call from a reporter.
And he said I don't
usually do this,
but I gave your book to
my nine-year-old son.
And he's gone and put
on his Sunday suit,
and now he's marching
around my house,
demanding equality for everyone.
Imagine if we could develop
a social consciousness
in every nine-year-old
in America.
What that would mean
for the next generation
and what they would be
capable of doing, particularly
if they were well-informed and
capable of using nonviolence
in a disciplined
and orderly way.
It's not just a philosophy.
It's a tactic.
And it's the only tactic
that truly will work.
There was a reviewer
in France, and he
used a phrase that
stuck with me.
He called it a weapon
of mass instruction.
I never thought I would
be able to participate
in creating something like that.
But as we stand here now, about
13 months after it's released,
the Washington
Post said it needs
to be in every school
and library in America.
NPR called it the next mouse.
I called it beginner's luck.
But it's because John Lewis'
story is so important.
We see a generation
of young people
who don't know how to make
a difference sometimes,
and particularly, with
all the resources we
have with technology.
And we have to teach
them that nonviolence
is the viable path forward.
I handle tech and telecom issues
in the congressman's office.
And I also do his social media,
so I'm basically head nerd.
And we're taking over the world.
We have to admit now, we
almost have a hegemonic state.
We're winning.
But what I'm constantly
struggling with
is the concept of
what would Dr. King
or what would Gandhi have
done with these tools?
It's a profound question.
And more importantly,
where is Google Organize?
Where is a Google March?
These technologies allow
people to be reached
in such a broad way that
we've never had access before,
and we're just starting to
see the beginning of it.
You think about the
Tahrir Square Revolution.
I'll draw this
connection for you.
It was Facebook that
helped them organize,
but it was Martin Luther
King and the Montgomery story
translated into Arabic that was
distributed just before they
started organizing.
So we can connect those pieces.
If we can get them
to ask the questions
and then use the
technology to organize,
the potential to remake
our society is limitless.
And I think that's exactly
what you're trying to do here.
So that's why I appreciate
you having us and letting
us bring "March."
Because we want to
be that first step,
so that the young people
ask the questions,
and then they use your
tools to make it a reality.
So I'll be brief.
I just thank you guys
so much for having me.
This is a real thrill.
I was in college and
started a television station
using Google Video
back in the day.
So it's a real honor to be here.
Thank you guys so much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Congressman,
what really
struck me was the story that
you mentioned about your father
having been a tenant farmer and
buying the land for $300 that's
still in your family today.
And when I think
about that, I think
about the incredible
upward mobility
that's afforded to
people and to families
by being able to go
from working just
for their monthly income to
actually generating value
for themselves and their family.
So my question for
you is what do you
see as the biggest opportunity
for the Federal Government
to help people who currently
are only living paycheck
to paycheck to actually
be able to develop some
of that equity for
themselves and their family
for the long term?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: Well,
I think the Federal Government
needs to do more to help people
that have been left and left
behind.
To make small loans available
with very low interest, maybe
in some instances
probably not any interest.
People just need a little help--
just need a helping hand--
to help make people a
little more independent.
We don't do it enough.
We should see that every
child receive the best
possible education, especially
in poor neighborhoods
in rural America.
That's why I've taken
such a strong stand
for comprehensive
immigration reform.
To help people move
up, and the people
will not live in a state
of want, a state of need.
You know, we're one of
the wealthiest countries
on the planet, and we need
to use some of our resources
to help and not continue
to make more bombs
and missiles and guns.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you, Congressmen
and Andrew, for coming.
I'm actually going to Ferguson
at the end of the week
to support group there
called Amplify Ferguson.
It's a team of media people
who are using technology
to give voices to the people
outside of this regular news
cycle, now that no one's really
focusing on people in Ferguson.
I'm helping with some
civic engagement workshops
that they have on Saturday.
I, myself, and not trained
in civic engagement.
I just was really
drawn to this cause.
And so I'm wondering
from you all, what
do you think about communities
like Ferguson and Ferguson?
What's missing there
in terms of how people
are using government
or getting involved?
Honestly, what would you
teach, if you were me,
when I go there this weekend?
And what you think is
most effective for youth
versus adults in that community?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
Andrew may want to respond,
but I would say
prepare yourself.
Before we've been on
any sit-in, the Freedom
Ride, the march from Selma to
Montgomery, the Mississippi
Summer Project, we studied.
And today there's all
type of literature.
Watch "Eyes on the Prize."
There's an NBC white paper that
came out many, many years ago,
which the late Chad Huntley
narrated the white paper
about the Nashville
sit-in story.
And in the book you'll
see the do's and don'ts
Back then we didn't have
a website, Facebook.
We didn't have Google.
We need even have a fax machine.
We had the old
mimeograph machine.
But we used what we
had to change America.
You have to be creative.
I think in Ferguson
people have got
to become active in
the political process.
It doesn't make sense
that so few people get out
and vote there.
As I've said many, many times
to my colleagues and to people
all around the country
that the vote is powerful.
In this precious.
It's almost sacred.
And we have to use it
to get things done.
The more young people,
more minority, more women,
get out and turn
out-- all of us just
turn out and show up and cast
a vote-- we can remake America,
make it better for everybody.
ANDREW AYDIN: I think
the most important thing
to keep in mind is
to look to our past
and see what worked before.
I think it would be very helpful
if many of the organizations
there modeled themselves
after the Nashville Student
Movement, which was
largely believed
to be the most
disciplined and orderly
of the individual
student movements.
Read Emerson.
Read Thoreau.
Read Gandhi.
Study nonviolence, because
the most important part
is the details.
Right?
Where is the
statement of demands?
Before they left on
the Freedom Rides,
they mailed a specific letter
to the Attorney General,
to the President and the press
with their specific demands
for what they were
trying to achieve.
Right?
There is a way that
has worked in the past,
and it's going to work again.
We just have to make sure that
everybody knows how to do it.
That's why we're doing "March."
That's why you should use Martin
Luther King and the Montgomery
story or "March" or these tools.
I mean, we're not
doing something
that hasn't worked before.
And, as you look out there,
you see people who are thirsty.
They want to know.
They want to know
how do I do this?
And we've just got to
get it into their hands.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And just so you know,
I'm going to try
to get some of these
books to give out
while I'm down there as well.
ANDREW AYDIN: Great.
Thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: Good.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Thanks for coming.
My question is about
the forms of racism
that are a little bit
more harder to detect,
more insidious.
So, I mean, there's
instances like Ferguson,
which are like forms of violence
that we can physically see.
But there seems to
be like a lot of I
can call quote, unquote,
invisible racism,
structural conditions or
economic stratification
that makes life on certain
minorities very difficult.
And so, how do things
like nonviolence,
per se, actually prevent things
like structural blockages
that prevent people from
voting in the first place?
And how do people like
us who are privileged
do something substantive
to actually help
people who are
structurally disadvantaged?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
Well, you have a voice.
You're smart.
You have the ability.
You have the capacity.
You could use the
new technology.
You could communicate.
And you have to help
inform and educate people.
When Martin Luther King, Junior,
would be preaching sometime
in Atlanta at his
father's church later when
they co-pastored, he
would be preaching,
and his father would
say-- Daddy King,
we called him-- would
say, "Make it plain, son.
Make it plain."
And he just kept
saying make it plain.
I think you can
help make it plain.
People like to hide stuff-- like
to hide it in the dark corner
or some place under
the American rug.
We have to help bring it out,
bring it out into the open
into the light.
So in a sense, why would members
of Congress and 200 citizens
go and deliberating
court getting arrested?
We want to put a face on it.
We want to make it real.
We want to send it to
the Speaker of the House.
You bring this
bill to the floor.
The Senate passed it.
We have the votes to pass it.
So you have to help put
the spotlight on it.
And just one day
will not necessarily.
I tell people all the time
that the struggle is not
a struggle that
lasts for a few days
or a few weeks or a few years.
It is a struggle of a lifetime
to create what Dr. King called
a beloved community or to create
an America community, a war
community at peace with itself.
Be creative.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Just want to thank
you both for coming out.
My question pertains to
sort of piggybacking off
of other people's questions.
We talked a lot about how
working at a place like Google
sort of empowers us to have the
ability to send out a message
or whatever about bringing
the country together
and all that stuff,
but Congressman Lewis,
you probably know
this better anyone,
I feel like within the past
10, 20 years has actually
become more fragmented,
the messages,
because before 20 years ago,
there was only three news
channels you could go
to-- ABC, NBC, or CBS.
It had to be more centrist
view that was being displayed.
It had to reach out
and appeal to everyone.
Now with everything
fragmented you
have your Fox News and your
MSNBC and your Drudge Report
and so on and so forth.
Everyone is sort of
siloing themselves
in a particular message.
There was a lot of reports
about the difference
in African American
responses to events
at Ferguson versus
white responses.
And one of the key insights
into that was well,
the Caucasian Americans
mostly hang out
with Caucasian Americans,
and therefore, only
reinforce the views
that they already had.
And so, with that being said,
how, even though the technology
and opportunity
is there, it seems
like it's being used for
the opposite of bringing
the country together.
It's used to pull people apart.
So, sort of, how do we actually
go about fixing those gaps
and those divides
given that everybody
has the opportunity
and the source to a,
find the true message, but
also listen to the message
that they want to
hear and sort of try
to reconcile both
of those facts.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
Well, I've said to Andrew
and I've said to some of my
colleagues in the Congress
from time to time, I've
said in the Congress we
need to conduct some
nonviolent workshops.
Just bring in members
of Congress together.
Because the American people
think we're so divided,
into a larger sense,
we are divided.
So one of the things I've been
doing with an organization
called Faith and Politics
for the past 15 years,
taking members of Congress,
taking business executives,
taking students and others,
to Selma, to Montgomery,
to Birmingham, to meet
some of the people,
to meet some of
the foot soldiers,
to meet the family of the
four little girls that
were bombed and killed.
To go-- and you have people,
Southerners, black, white.
You have people living in the
Midwest or the West Coast that
have never traveled
in the South.
And they go and walk
through these churches,
through this historic
site, they meet people.
And they'll change.
Or to have someone who beat
you 50 years ago and then
come up or come to your
office in Washington and say,
you know, I'm sorry.
I want to apologize.
Will you forgive me?
And to have a chief of police
in Montgomery, Alabama,
almost two years ago,
but more than a year ago,
a young guy who
was not even born,
said to me, "Congressman,
when you came here in 1961,
more than 50 years ago,
our police department
was not kind to you
and your colleagues.
We withdrew."
He was not a police officer.
He was not even born.
But he said we withdrew.
We let our angry mark beat you.
He said, but our police
department today is better.
Before anyone becomes a member
of this police department,
they must know
something about what
happened in Montgomery,
what happened
in Selma, what
happened in Birmingham.
He went on talking.
This chief is white.
His deputy is African American.
The young deputy
didn't even know
the chief was going
to go down that road.
And then before it was over,
the chief said something like,
"Congressman, because
of my admiration for you
and your colleagues
of what you did,
I'm going to take off my badge.
I'm going to give it to you.
I'm going to present
you my badge."
That's what he said.
And I said Chief,
you can't do that.
You the Chief of Police.
You need your badge.
And the young African
American deputy lost it.
He just started
crying, because he
didn't know his chief
wasn't going to do that.
And then the whole audience,
even members of Congress,
Democrats and Republicans,
black and white, Latinos
and Asian Americans, all
sitting there crying.
So sometimes we
have to find ways.
Sometimes it may not
intention, but it
tends to reach people and
catch them in the gut.
ANDREW AYDIN: And,
you know, that's not
a question that wasn't asked
during the Civil Rights
Movement.
When Dr. King wrote a letter
from a Birmingham jail,
there were whites in the
community who said, you know,
why are you agitating now?
Why are you doing this?
And there were differing
perspectives based on race.
But I think what
we need to do today
is we need to look at
some of these issues
where they stretch clear
across racial boundaries
and are, in fact,
these social depression
mechanisms like student loans.
I mean, you've got a generation
of young people growing up
with more debt than
they ever have.
And he Federal Government is
profiting off of those loans.
And they're using that
money to pay for war.
And that's not right.
But I think if you started
off and found a common ground
like that that stretches across
all groups that are suffering
from it, and you did as
LBJ told Martin Luther
King to do in the
winter of 1964,
and make Congress do
something about it.
If they all organized around.
At UC Occupy, they paid
down $4 million in debt.
Let's make Congress pay
down $4 billion in debt.
And then find that
common ground,
and then build from there.
You really could change things.
But you've got to find
that common ground.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Congressman John Lewis,
I thank you so much
not only for being here, but
for everything that you've done,
which has allowed me to be here.
And Andrew, as a former
middle school teacher,
I thank you for
creating something
which would be so relevant
and so easily accessible
for my former students.
So, since we are here
at Google and thinking
through like for
my students, I'm
thinking through the
lines of my kids.
Like, this is great.
However, it may not be the
most accessible for them, just
buying books, et cetera.
What is Google's response,
or what would you
want Google's responsibility
to be in creating a platform
or sharing the miniseries
that you have created?
And also, what are your
plans for other books
for capturing our history?
ANDREW AYDIN: Well, so
this is just the first one.
Right?
And each one has a
different lesson.
This first one was to introduce
nonviolence as a tactic.
The next one we
deal with how you
make a movement a
national movement.
That's what the
Freedom Rides did.
And then how you deal
with that once it
does get on the
national stage, which
was the March on
Washington, and how
you deal with the
response from it, which
is the bombing of the church
and the death of the four
little school girls
on September 15, 1963,
just three weeks after
the March on Washington.
Right?
You know, the way I think
Google should be participate
in this is sharing information.
I don't think people adequately
understand how much governance
goes on at the local
level around them.
Imagine if you just had a
database where you could just
simply look up this is
where I live and this
is what I care
about, and then you
saw every local meeting that
was happening around there.
And how the legislation
or the bills that they
were considering was
made plain, and it
was shown to each person.
And then they could
go to the meeting
and have their
opportunity to speak.
Sure.
You'd frustrate some
county local officials.
The meetings would
go a little longer.
But that's what
they signed up for,
and that's what they
should be doing.
And if a middle
schooler, of all things,
shows up and says I still
think that's not right,
I dare an elected official
to argue with them.
You've got so many resources.
And information,
above all else is,
is the most important thing.
Make this society more informed.
Let them know what is going
on in their community in a way
that, as Daddy King says, as
the Congressman has pointed out,
makes it plain.
And we'll keep doing
the books to show them
the history and the
tactics that were used,
and you give them the
information and the tools
to do it again.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Congressman
Lewis, Mr. Aydin,
thank you so much
for being here.
Congressman, it's
such an honor to hear
you speak and have you impart
these lessons from history that
still impact us
definitely today.
My question has to do
with a couple things.
The first part is that in light
of the events of Ferguson,
as we've discussed,
in the reports that
show that literally hundreds
of African Americans,
specifically, are
targeted because of race
and unjustifiably killed, and
these actions go unprosecuted.
And as you spoke of
the Voting Rights Act,
the Supreme Court recently
struck down Section Four, one
of the most important
aspects and most
of the important
enforcing aspects
of the Voting Rights Act.
In light of these
steep, backward steps,
as what I would
see them, happening
in our modern day in
our day of progress,
and in light of all the
media attention around it,
in light of technology
used to raise awareness
about these issues-- there are
literally millions of tweets,
thousands of articles about
these issues all the time.
In light of all of that, we
see very little reform and very
little structural change
despite this awareness.
So in your mind and what
you've seen in your experience?
What is that missing link
between awareness and action
and actual reform?
My second part to
that is, in my mind
I see our elected officials
and the federal government,
our agencies, and
state governments
in those attendant structures
as that middle link
between the public and
reform, legislative reform,
what have you.
Are you seeing any progress in
those fronts in your position
as an elected
official in Congress
that can give us hope that maybe
this action, this awareness,
will actually result in
some structural progress?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Well, I truly
believe that the
vote is powerful.
I was in the chamber
when the Supreme Court
debated and considered
the Voting Rights
Act, section four.
And when that decision came
down I felt like crying,
but I wouldn't cry.
It meant everything to me.
I gave a little blood on that
bridge for the right to vote.
Almost died.
And I think there are
forces in America that
want to take us back
to another period.
But there are also forces must
speak up and speak out and say
we've made too much progress
and we're not going back.
The struggle is an
ongoing struggle.
You know, Ferguson
was a few weeks ago.
And we're not there,
but we will get there.
That's why this election
is so important.
It is a must.
If we fail to turn
out all-- I don't need
to say this to people
in California--
but in some other parts of
America-- we fail to turn out,
then we can go backwards.
And we must continue
to go forward.
And put people in places
where they will speak up
and speak out and organize.
I've said it all
along that I think
the America people
are too quiet.
Just too quiet, too complacent.
If this is 1960 or 1965, there
would be hundreds of thousands
of people in the
streets of America.
After the beating of us
in Selma on March 7, 1965,
there were major demonstrations
in every major city in America,
on 80 college
campuses, overnight.
It happened on a Sunday.
By that Tuesday
people were sitting
in the White House, the
Department of Justice.
Even the President said his
children couldn't sleep,
his two daughters
couldn't sleep,
because people were singing
"We Shall overcome."
We have to get out there again
and push and pull and have
some created tension.
So I-- you have to
go out and organize.
I don't know.
If we didn't have
what you have today,
I don't know what we would
have been able to accomplish.
We got to use these tools,
use these instruments,
use the information,
to recreate America.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Congressman,
Andrew, thank you
both for your life of service.
My name is Seth Marvin.
I work here on the
Googlers Give Team.
And we help employees volunteer,
and give away their money.
And I used to work at
City Year, and I thank you
for your service.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
I'm a City Year jacket.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You're an incredible supporter
of City Year and National
Service.
So thank you for that.
In the spirit of City
Year, we carried backpacks,
we wore a uniform.
And I'm curious.
You mentioned the backpack
that you wore over the--
in the March over the bridge.
I've been over that bridge.
It's amazing to sort of
walk in your footsteps
and see what you've
been able to accomplish.
But I'm curious.
What would you put
in your backpack
today if you're going
out to lead that march?
And Andrew, for you, I'd
love to hear more about--
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
What instruments would I
have, Andrew, in that backpack?
AUDIENCE: What would be in that?
You mentioned an apple,
an orange, a couple books.
What would be in
that backpack today?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
Well, you know, back,
growing up the way I grew up,
we didn't have a telephone.
We didn't have a subscription
to a newspaper we were so poor.
But my grandfather had one.
And each day when he would
finish reading his newspaper,
we would get his
newspaper and read it.
Some of our neighbors had,
what we called party line.
I would have a telephone
in that backpack.
I would be able to communicate.
And probably have maybe a
small computer or something.
And Andrew would teach
me all of the way.
He's the man.
Andrew what would you
advise me have in it?
ANDREW AYDIN: I think you
just need a phone these days.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS: Yeah.
Just a phone.
ANDREW AYDIN: Can
start a revolution
with this little device.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
But to be very frank,
I wish I had the backpack back.
People ask me all the time,
what happened to your backpack?
What happened to
your trench coat?
People from the Smithsonian,
from the Library of Congress.
We don't know what
happened to it.
AUDIENCE: And Andrew,
I'd love to hear more
about the tools
that you mentioned,
Google Organize
and Google March.
If you can answer
any more specifics
on what those might look like.
What are we missing
at this point?
ANDREW AYDIN: So, when
w get on social media,
the message can
spread like that.
We did the mug shot Tweet
a couple months ago,
and it was like 50,000
re-Tweets, because we
were so shocked that it
was only 53 years ago
that somebody went to
Parchment Print Prison
for using a white restroom.
Right?
These tools need to dramatize
these same struggles that
are going on today.
I think when we shine a bright
light-- the world light,
if you will-- on to some
of these injustices,
then people are much
more willing to act.
But above all else, we've
got to get people to show up.
We've got to find
a way to get people
to let their presence
be their voice.
We have a generation
now who's almost
bordering on becoming
armchair activists.
They post things and
they come complain
that they think it's wrong,
but when it comes down
to showing up and
putting pressure
on your elected officials,
because let's be honest,
most people in Congress
don't move without pressure.
It's been that way
for a long time.
It's not new to this Congress.
You have too few John Lewis's.
And so we have to get
people to show up.
That was the point of
the March on Washington.
And look how well it worked.
Maybe it sparked a
backlash, but in the end
it dramatized and helped
continue the efforts.
More importantly, look at the
Mississippi Freedom Summer.
Schwerner, Chaney,
and Goodman died
so that we could have a Civil
Rights Act and a Voting Rights
Act.
These people showed up.
They went to schools.
They educated themselves.
They organized.
So we have to make a
way to put these tools
in the hands of everybody.
First the lessons of
nonviolence, the history
of nonviolence, how it was
used successfully, and then
take it to that next step
and help people show up.
Help people mobilize.
It was just a few weeks ago that
we had a college student put
out a Tweet with a hashtag that
garnered 3,000 people marching
through the streets of
Atlanta in solidarity
of Ferguson, including
Congressman Lewis.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
And so many people
thought I was there.
They thought I was at Ferguson.
They saw me walking it in
the march, holding up my arm.
But that's--
ANDREW AYDIN: No.
And getting people to show up.
But I think also information.
We don't understand
and we don't fully
appreciate how much
governance actually
happens at the local level.
Right?
I mean, we're fighting
a fight right now
to get people
registered to vote.
And that's a local decision
first, at the county level
and then at the state level.
So how do you pressure
a Secretary of State
to recognize valid
voter applications when
they know that it will mean
that they will lose an election?
How do you pressure your
county-wide officials
to make it easier to
register and vote?
Right?
I mean we all vote on a Tuesday
and nobody gets the day off,
and we say everybody has
the opportunity to vote.
But the fact is that
most people have a job.
And they're tired
when they get home.
And they have to be into the
polling place by 7:00 o'clock.
I never get home
by 7:00 o'clock.
But Congressman
Lewis says take time.
Go vote.
Right?
We should make it
a national holiday.
We should press our Congress
to make it a national holiday.
We should make voting as easy
as drinking a glass of water.
Sorry.
I stole your line.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: That's OK.
That's OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
both for your service.
ANDREW AYDIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I either have
1,000 questions or none,
but I wanted to say
thank you so much
for what you've done for all
of us, because none of us
are free unless we're all free.
And I'm old enough-- I
was a young teenager when
you were marching
on that bridge,
and I remember seeing
the news stories
and not really understanding.
And just thank you very
much for your courage
and all your efforts
on behalf of all of us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you,
Congressman Lewis and Andrew.
So one of the things, I
feel, of my generation
is that we actually
feel the vote is
a pretty ineffective tool
for getting our voices heard.
And given that we're in Silicon
Valley where you see technology
playing a role to do more than
just spreading information
as in like being sort
of armchair activists
and being able to play a role
despite having a full time
job, what are the things you
think that, as technologists,
we can all do to
create more impact?
ANDREW AYDIN: Well,
I think it's time
for us to start the conversation
about online voting,
online voter registration,
and making it national idea.
It's oftentimes antiquated
rules with a cumbersome way
of doing it to get
people to show up.
And we make it too hard.
We have all this technology.
We should find new ways to
use it in the voting process.
It can be secure if
we work hard enough.
If Diebold can advocate
for using electronic voting
machines in their
election, then perhaps it's
time for us to look
at it for everybody
online as opposed to
just the touch screens,
because there was so much
controversy with that
that they supported it.
But I think there's
a flip side of that.
We can't advocate
that until everybody
has access to the internet.
I think it's time
for us to call--
are you familiar with
the lifeline program?
AUDIENCE: No.
ANDREW AYDIN: It's
something the FCC does
so that folks who live
below the poverty line
can have access to a cellphone.
Right?
I think we need to expand
that to include data
so that everybody can have
access to information.
If you're poor, if you're
under the poverty line,
you just get a phone
with data on it.
That's how people get
their information.
How are we expecting
people to be informed
if we don't give them
the tools to be informed?
We're cutting library budgets
at a record pace, which
used to be the only
place they could
get free access to the internet.
So we're going to take
it away from there.
We've got to push to give
it to them somewhere else.
And, I think, part
of it, too, is
that you're not going to
fix everything in a day.
And we're going to have to find
small things to build momentum.
So if it's expanding
the lifeline program
to include data for folks
living under the poverty line
and giving everybody access to
a phone with data, so be it.
It's better to spend
our money on that
than to spend it on bombs.
AUDIENCE: I think
all of us can agree.
ANDREW AYDIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Congressman
Lewis, for coming, and Andrew.
My question is about
truth and reconciliation.
I know that a lot
of the problems
here are between
different people
having-- they have different,
conflicting views about what
really happened.
And I think that people are
afraid to step forward and say
what happened in the '60s, what
happened with the lynchings,
and so there's this distrust
that kind of continues on.
So what are your
thoughts about that?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: I believe deeply
that's why we must move as
a people and as a nation.
There's still a lot
of hurt and pain.
I know individuals in
African American community.
The book came about
lynching, a small book.
It was an exhibit in
different parts of America.
People I know in African
American community
couldn't go to the museum or
to a church or to the school.
And there was some colleges
and universities in this South
were afraid to display it.
They thought something
would happen.
But we need to face the truth.
It did happen.
So you cannot hide it.
Face it.
And I think South
Africa has one up on us.
They did a better job of
bringing people together.
And that's what
we've been trying
to do on a limited basis in
parts of the American South,
in Alabama, when we
go back to Montgomery
and to Selma and to Birmingham.
Let people-- the people
that was on the other side,
black and white-- let
them come together.
I've gone back to Birmingham
on some of these trips,
and on one occasion
when I was back there,
a white gentleman
said, middle-aged,
said I want to
speak to John Lewis.
And someone said
he's right here.
And he said, Mr. Lewis, I
want to apologize to you
on behalf of all of the
white people of Alabama
for what we did.
We need to get there.
People in the
Congress, we're afraid.
We're afraid to
issue an apology.
The Congress, the National
Assembly of the United States
of America is afraid to say
we're sorry for slavery,
we're sorry for the
system of segregation
and racial discrimination.
So that legacy is still there.
It lingers.
AUDIENCE: And how it affects
today and what's going on today
and how it connects.
I think a lot of
people don't make
that connection between slavery,
racism, post-reconstruction,
and what's happening in our
cities today, and Ferguson.
I think people just don't
make that connection.
Also, I want to say
that there's definitely
people who are willing to
stand up because, you know,
Occupy was amazing.
I was totally blown
away that they
were able to get so many people
together across the city.
I think they probably lacked a
message or a concrete message.
And also, I just want
to say thank you.
I know I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for you.
So thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Thank you.
There's an exhibit at
the Library of Congress.
It should continue until
next September of '15.
Unreal, unbelievable.
So it may travel.
But it's a complete history
of the whole struggle
from the days of slavery.
AUDIENCE: I'll have to catch it.
Thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
Congressman Lewis.
You've talked a lot about
low voter participation
and turnouts.
And I feel like there have been
a lot of deliberate attempts
to breed cynicism
and the feeling
that our vote doesn't
matter, particularly
for people who are more
likely to support equality.
And one of the ways
that I've seen this done
is by splitting up elections.
Like, I remember
a conversation I
had with a Republican
strategist once
who talked about the
deliberate strategy
to hold special elections
and things like that,
because there's lower voter
turnouts in those elections,
and those people about tend to
skew older and skew wealthier
and skew more Republican.
And even in a lot
of local elections
are held at weird off times.
And I've missed more
than one election
when I moved to a
new city because it
was like there was nothing
in any of the media
that I get that let me know
that the election happened
until there was a news story
three days later about who won.
And even when I have
voted sometimes,
by the time you get down
to family court judge,
my question is why is this even
an elected position, much less
having a sense of who would
be the better candidate here.
So my question
is, what can we do
to counteract the
forces that want
to discourage voter turnout
through spreading out
elections, and to help
it be easier for people
to become informed voters?
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: I think it's
important for local partisan
or nonpartisan organizations
and groups, like the League of
Women Voters, good government
groups, to lobby, to organize
and get legislation passed,
to change the type of voting.
But my philosophies
are also that you
should vote in every election,
even if it's only the dog
catcher, you want to
vote for the dog catcher
or vote against the dog catcher.
But vote.
It's just that important.
In our young people,
we have to get
people in the habit
of participating,
minorities in the South,
in the habit of voting,
in the habit of participating.
And we should take
our young children
when we go to the polls.
Take them to the polls with
us and let them punch and do
whatever you do
so they can see it
become a part of
their existence.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This may be a bit more of a
statement than a question.
First off, I wanted to say that
I'm a very recent Californian,
having here moved
here two years ago,
and spent the preceding
20 years in Atlanta,
and was extremely proud to
have had you as my Congressman
for a great, great
deal of that time.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN
LEWIS: Well, I try
to do my best as a
member of Congress.
This young man here said I've
been here since he was three.
AUDIENCE: And I
wanted to thank you
all for drawing the
sort of line of history,
because well, my wife
is older than I am
and she was involved in the
Vietnam Movement and protests
against Vietnam.
My father-- we lived in Texas,
and he sat at lunch counters.
But one of my great honors
as part of the continuing
movement, I personally met my
wife protesting US involvement
in Central America
in the '80s was
to be able to meet
representative of the Abraham
Lincoln brigades from
the Spanish Civil War.
And I was made acutely
aware of the legacy
of the movements of the '30s.
And so, it's a
continuous movement,
and I'm proud to be part
of this river in some form.
And I'm very honored
to meet a giant.
In that said, thank you.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS:
Thank you very much, sir.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]